but first we're going to start with this
the U.S Britain and France are all
strongly criticizing a Russian claim
that Ukraine may drop a radioactive
dirty bomb on its own territory Ukraine
says only Russia will consider launching
such an attack Russian missiles and
drones have caused serious damage in the
southern city near the area where
Ukraine's Army is massing for a likely
major offensive Ollie Williams is in
Ukraine with more on this part of the
story so Holly what is all this talk
about a dirty bomb
good morning well Russia is claiming
that Ukraine could detonate a
radioactive device on its own territory
an allegation with apparently no
evidence to back it up that's been
dismissed as false by the U.S here in
Ukraine it's instead sparked fears that
Russia could itself be about to use a
radioactive weapon
in a phone call yesterday Russia says
its defense minister Sergey shoigu told
Secretary of Defense Lloyd Austin that
Ukraine could be preparing a so-called
dirty bomb a dirty bomb has never been
used before is not a nuclear explosion
and would be far less harmful but by
using conventional explosives to spread
radioactive material it's an effective
weapon of Terror and could contaminate
an area for years in a joint statement
the U.S the UK and France rejected
Russia's transparently false allegations
saying the world would see through any
attempt to use it as a pretext for
escalation
if Russia claims Ukraine's preparing
something it means one thing said
Ukrainian President Vladimir zelenski
suggesting it's actually Russia that
plans to use a dirty bomb the U.S has
repeatedly accused Russia of
disinformation and so-called false flag
operations in Ukraine staging violent
incidents as an excuse for its brutal
Invasion all these are consistent with
the Playbook the Russians have used
before
to set up a false justification to act
against Ukraine
and in reality it's Vladimir Putin who's
threatened to use nuclear weapons
the Ukrainian energy Minister told us
that in this country they believe him do
you think it's possible that Vladimir
Putin will use a tactical nuclear weapon
here in Ukraine I think you'd do
everything
I am expected from there now everything
Russia's warning that the situation here
in Ukraine is trending towards quote
uncontrolled escalation in truth though
Russian forces appear to be under
pressure they've rapidly lost territory
and they recently switched tactics
targeting Ukraine's power grid Tony
yeah that phrase uncontrolled escalation
caught me as well Holly Williams for us
in Ukraine Holly thank you very much for